salut romain non qu'est ce tu manges un
petit cocktail qu'un pote m'a conseillé
pour être en forme
un code dans un mélange de jus de fruits
de plantes des peas et d'antibiotiques
des antibiotiques
oui bof tous un peu il y en avait en rab
à tendance rock tu fais exprès pour être
dans l'intro c'est ça ben bon les
antibiotiques
vous connaissez oui forcément on a déjà
pris depuis tout petit même
donc vous savez à quoi ça sert vous
gérez vous êtes sûr non parce que c'est
souvent quand un truc est un peu trop
familier et qu'on fait les choses de
manières comme ça un peu automatique
sans réfléchir
on fait des erreurs on non ou parce que
moi j'ai quand même entendu deux trois
trucs pas fou sur les antibiotiques ah
bon vous savez quoi on va faire un petit
point sur la question en démontant 7
bullshit sur les antibiotiques
parce que globalement vaut mieux se
poser trop de questions que pas assez
moi quand j'ai la crève via que les
antibiotiques qui marchent alors déjà le
concept de crève ça recouvre tout un tas
de réalité super différentes avec des
signes vaguement comme un genre le nez
qui coule la toux mal à la gorge
la fatigue des douleurs parfois de la
fièvre et cetera
mais en vrai ça peut être un rhume ça
peut être la grippe et ça soye pas
pareil par contre ce qui est sûr c'est
que ça se soigne avec des antibiotiques
parce que c'est des maladies causées par
des virus et que les antibiotiques ça
marche que sur les bactéries
c'est même un peu plus compliqué que ça
mais ça on va y revenir quand on a de la
fièvre
comment des antibiotiques banon a priori
l'erreur vient du fait que pour les gens
fièvre égale inflexion et antibiotiques
égale médicaments pour soigner les
infections
sauf que 1 les virus ça entraîne aussi
de la fièvre
je suis de la grippe par exemple et 2
les antibiotiques ça ne soigne que les
infections causées par des bactéries
donc la fièvre ça suffit pas il faut
savoir si vous avez une bactérie et
choisir l'antibiotique qui marche sur
elle et ça c'est le boulot du médecin ça
se vend pas comme ça ouais mais bon
antibiotiques c'est pas dangereux donc
au pire ça marche pas puis voilà alors
ce qui est embêtant par contre c'est
qu'à force de mal utiliser les
antibiotiques pour soigner des maladies
virales par exemple ou en prenant un
antibiotique qui marchent pas sur la
bactérie qu'on a les matériels en ont
profité pour s'adapter
y compris les bactéries qu'on a tous
dans les intestins sur la peau etc et
qui nous maintiennent en bonne santé
sofia se retrouve un endroit où elles
devraient pas certaines bactéries ont
développé des résistances aux
antibiotiques et ça ça pose des vrais
problèmes mais ça on en a déjà parlé
dans une vidéo je vous remets le lien
dans la description pour vous rafraîchir
la mémoire
la dernière fois que j'ai eu une angine
mon médecin m'a prescrit des
antibiotiques et il en reste donc je les
garde pour m'approcher longines nope
déjà faut savoir que la majorité des
angines est causée par des virus et on
ne donne des antibiotiques que pour
celles causées par des bactéries
donc si votre mère engine et et
bactériennes les antibiotiques
ils ont marché mais marcheront pas si la
suivante et virales vient maintenant des
tests de diagnostic rapides qui
permettent à votre médecin de déterminer
en quelques minutes si votre engine est
d'origine bactérienne ou pas quand vous
pensez avoir une angine il faut aller
chez le médecin
et s'il vous reste des antibiotiques
dans la boîte à la fin d'un traitement
il faut les ramener à la pharmacie parce
que de toute façon on vous sert plus à
rien et c'est même dangereux d'en
prendre son ordonnance oui les bactéries
qui développent des résistances vous
savez vous avez pas d'oublier j'étais
malade mais tous mais signe ont disparu
donc je peux arrêter les antibiotiques
avant la fin fait pas ça les
antibiotiques
ça tue les bactéries et il faut un
certain temps pour tout les tuer alors
au bout de quelques jours il peut en
rester tellement plu que vous avez
l'impression d'être guéri mais il en
reste et si vous arrêtez le traitement
avant la fin ça peut leur permettre de
développer des résistances au contact
d'autres bactéries
on en a aussi parlé dans la vidéo
précédente donc prenez bien la dose
prescrite par le médecin le nom de jours
prévus pour toute les éliminer trois
fois par jour pendant une semaine par
exemple ça veut dire trois fois par jour
pendant une semaine
pas deux fois par jour pendant 10 jours
ou un comprimé le matin et 2 le soir on
sait pas sa faute si mon corps a
développé des résistances aux
antibiotiques
ça sert à rien j'entraîne ou là
attention c'est pas votre corps qui a
développé des résistances aux
antibiotiques c'est certaines bactéries
qui sont devenues résistantes mais pas
toutes donc quand une bactérie vous rend
malade
fo prend
lebon antibiotiques celui qui la tue
pour pu être malade faut soigner
évidemment mais pas tout seul dans son
coin juste pas le faire n'importe
comment et consulter son médecin toute
façon les bactéries résistantes et on
n'a qu'à l'hôpital
donc si je suis pas hospitaliser ça me
concerne pas et non c'est vrai qu'on
entend le plus souvent par les bactéries
résistantes à l'hôpital d'abord parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de malades donc
beaucoup de bactéries et plus de chances
qu'elle se promène de patient en patient
est parce qu on y utilise beaucoup les
antibiotiques mais des bactéries
résistantes si on a aussi à l'extérieur
comme les escherichia coli par exemple
c'est une bactérie qu'on a tous dans le
tube digestif
une de celles dont on parlait tout à
l'heure qu'on a à l'état normal dans
l'intestin
eh ben elle peut présenter des
résistances et causé notamment des
infections urinaires si elles migrent et
qu'elle se retrouve là où ils devraient
pas et surtout des bactéries il y en a
partout tout le temps et l'idée c'est de
ne pas les exposer inutilement aux
antibiotiques pour éviter qu'elles
deviennent résistantes
justement vous voyez non ça concerne pas
que les hôpitaux ça concerne tout le
monde
les hôpitaux et les médecins ils font ce
qu'il faut pour lutter contre
l'antibiorésistance mais on a tous notre
rôle à jouer
donc si on veut faire un petit bilan 1
quand vous êtes malade aller chez le
médecin
oui je sais ça va sans dire mais ça va
toujours mieux en le disant
2 quand on vous donne des antibiotiques
rené bien la dose prescrite pendant le
nombre de jours prévus pas plus pas
moins
3 quand vous avez fini gardez pas les
boîtes pour une prochaine fois
ou pour quelqu'un d'autre vous vous
rasez antibiotiques a mêlé à la
pharmacie voit la dtcc fini pour
aujourd'hui
si vous avez des questions sur les
antibiotiques ou sur un autre sujet bab
vous savez vous trouvez on se retrouve
très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici
là prenez soin de vous et prenez soin
des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]